Traductor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Albert Camus creció rodeado de violencia.
Su tierra natal en Argelia estaba sumida
en un conflicto entre nativos argelinos
y los colonizadores europeos franceses.
Perdió a su padre
en la Primera Guerra Mundial,
y se le consideró no apto
para luchar en la Segunda.
Combatiendo la tuberculosis en Francia
y confrontando la devastación de la guerra
como periodista de la resistencia,
Camus se desesperó.
No podía entender el significado
detrás de todo este derramamiento
de sangre y sufrimiento sin fin.
Se preguntó: ¿si el mundo no tenía sentido
podrían seguir teniendo valor
nuestras vidas individuales?
Muchos de los contemporáneos
de Camus exploraban preguntas similares
bajo la bandera de una nueva
filosofía llamada Existencialismo.
Los existencialistas creían que
las personas nacían como tábulas rasas,
cada uno responsable de crear significado
a su vida en medio de un mundo caótico.
Pero Camus rechazó
su escuela de pensamiento.
Argumentó que todas las personas
nacieron con naturaleza humana compartida
que los unía hacia objetivos comunes.
Un objetivo era buscar significado a pesar
de la crueldad arbitraria del mundo.
Camus vio el deseo de
significado de la humanidad
y la silenciosa indiferencia del Universo
como dos piezas incompatibles de un puzzle
y pensó que tratar de unirlas
era fundamentalmente absurdo.
Esta tensión se convirtió en el corazón
de la Filosofía del Absurdo de Camus
que consideró que la vida
era inherentemente fútil.
Explorar cómo vivir sin sentido,
se convirtió en el principio rector
detrás del trabajo inicial de Camus,
el cual llamó "su ciclo del absurdo".
La estrella de este ciclo,
y primera novela publicada de Camus,
ofrece una respuesta bastante sombría.
"El extranjero" sigue a Meursault,
un joven emocionalmente distante
que no atribuye mucho significado a nada.
No llora en el funeral de su madre,
apoya el plan de su vecino
para humillar a una mujer,
incluso comete un crimen violento,
pero Meaursault no siente remordimientos.
Para él, el mundo no tiene sentido
y el juicio moral no tiene cabida en él.
Esta actitud crea hostilidad
entre Meursault
y la sociedad metódica en la que habita,
aumentando lentamente su alineación
hasta el climax explosivo de la novela.
A diferencia de
su despreciado protagonista,
Camus fue notorio
por su filosofía honesta.
"El extranjero" lo catapultó a la fama,
y Camus continuó produciendo trabajos
que exploraron el valor de
la vida en medio del absurdo
muchos de los cuales giraban
en torno a la misma pregunta filosófica:
Si la vida realmente no tiene sentido,
¿cometer suicidio es
la única respuesta razonable?
La respuesta de Camus fue un rotundo "no".
Puede que no haya ninguna explicación
para nuestro mundo injusto,
pero elegir vivir de todas formas
es la expresión más profunda
de nuestra genuina libertad.
Camus explica esto
en uno de sus ensayos más famosos
que se centra en el mito griego de Sísifo.
Sísifo era un rey que engañó a los dioses,
y fue condenado a subir sin cesar
una roca por una colina.
La crueldad de su castigo
radica en su singular futilidad,
pero Camus sostiene que toda
la humanidad está en la misma posición.
Y solo cuando aceptamos
el sinsentido de nuestras vidas
podemos afrontar lo absurdo
con la cabeza bien alta.
Como dice Camus, cuando el rey decide
empezar su incansable tarea una vez más,
"Uno puede imaginar a Sísifo feliz".
Los contemporáneos de Camus
no aceptaban la futilidad.
Muchos existencialistas
abogaron por una revolución violenta
para poner patas arriba sistemas que
creían que privaban a la gente
de representación y propósito.
Camus respondió con su segundo trabajo:
el ciclo de la revolución.
En "El hombre rebelde", explora
la rebelión como un acto creativo,
en vez de uno destructivo.
Camus creía que invertir
la dinámica del poder
solo conduciría a un ciclo
interminable de violencia.
En cambio, la forma de evitar
un derramamiento de sangre innecesario
es establecer una comprensión pública
de nuestra naturaleza humana compartida.
Irónicamente, fue este ciclo de
ideas relativamente pacíficas
lo que desencadenó repercusiones
con muchos colegas escritores y filósofos.
A pesar de la controversia,
Camus comenzó a trabajar en su novela
más larga y personal hasta el momento:
un trabajo autobiográfico
titulado "El primer hombre".
La novela estaba destinada a ser
el primer paso a una nueva
y prometedora dirección:
el ciclo del amor.
Pero en 1960, Camus murió
repentinamente en un accidente de auto
que solo puede ser descrito
como sinsentido y absurdo.
Aunque el mundo nunca vio
su ciclo del amor,
sus ciclos de rebelión y absurdo continúan
resonando entre los lectores hoy en día.
Su concepto del absurdo se convirtió
en parte del mundo de la literatura,
la filosofía del siglo XX,
e incluso la cultura pop.
Hoy, Camus sigue siendo un guía confiable
para momentos de incertidumbre;
sus ideas impregnando desafiante
inspiración en un mundo sin sentido
en lugar de derrota.